ghost stories is a new British horror
film that I've been dying to see I've
heard a lot of things about this since
it premiered a lot of festivals and I
was pretty excited to see if this film
lives up to the hype that I've heard
from critics and audience members at
those festivals this film is about a guy
who's a super-duper skeptic he has a TV
show called psychic cheats where he
debunks people who say they can contact
the supernatural and he tries to prove
that it's all a gigantic hoax
he's been skeptical about the
supernatural for most of his life and he
has found that by doing so it has
allowed him to have a firmer grasp on
his own reality but when he comes across
three Case Files that details some
paranormal experiences he finds them
inexplicable and thus he becomes haunted
by these hauntings and the fact that he
can't explain them this film was awesome
I really loved this movie I thought that
it was one of the creepiest horror films
I've seen in a very long time
and it's because it understands what all
good horror films do scary things it's
not just about blood it's not about gore
it's not about violence and it's
certainly not about a ghost that might
be in the corner or something like those
things are fun and this movie is very
entertaining in that respect it has a
lot of good tongue-in-cheek elements to
it but this film understands that the
real horror is about the pain and the
regret of things that have perhaps
happened in your family or in your past
things that could really happen to you
that perhaps you've never come to terms
with and it explores all of those things
in very awesome fashion and through our
lead character we learned that his past
involving his father was rocky at best
he had a difficult upbringing we see
some childhood video of a Bar Mitzvah
and various gatherings where the family
just did not get along but as this
skeptic that he's now become we see him
visit the main subjects of these Case
Files and interview them and they're
very disturbed about the things they've
seen and as they begin to describe these
past events we witness their stories
play out almost like it's an anthology
film we have three separate short films
kind of that are in this feature that
are extremely unsettling
each one of them building upon the last
each one of them having a very
satisfying through line
that you can witness if you pay
attention to the things that are on the
screen little things in the corners the
colors certain numbers things that
connect them really great stuff I
thought this was a very very clever
horror film and I really enjoyed it
until the last few minutes but I didn't
hate it I didn't hate the way the film
decided to conclude it's just something
that I've seen before and it
disappointed me that it went in a
direction that I was used to because so
much of the rest of the film was so
different and very unique this is
directed by two people one of them is
the main star according to the IMDB page
of Jeremy Dyson one of the directors he
went to Leeds University and got a
degree in philosophy and that's very
clear in this film because it really
Ponder's the human mind the tagline is
the brain sees what it wants to see and
this film is definitely interested in
perusing those dark corners of our mind
whether or not we can come to terms with
things that we see or that we feel like
we've experienced or if we'd rather just
block that out and pretend like it
didn't even happen so in those three
segments where we witnessed those Case
Files come to life there's a lot of
great horror movie imagery and things
that go bump in the night that are going
to startle you or give you the
goosebumps there's one image in
particular that actually gave me chills
from from head to toe and purely because
of how great and wonderful it was
executed but it's not just a horror film
in that aspect it really does try to
dive into the human psyche which is
probably my favorite aspect of this
movie but as I said the last few minutes
I don't want to say it's a betrayal it
just it kind of felt like less of oh my
god and more of a oh yeah yeah that
makes sense I guess yeah but I do want
to see the film again because I feel
like the second viewing will be much
richer and the fact that so much of the
film despite some of the more familiar
tropes it explores was executed in such
a compelling and unique way I really
recommend you see ghost stories
especially if you're a horror fan I'm
gonna give it an a-minus
if you guys get a chance to see this I
would recommend check and get out please
do stay tuned for more reviews very soon
I'm gonna have my pre-1970s review
coming to you very soon and that is
psycho I can't wait to talk about that
film it's warmer outside and whenever it
gets warmer outside I get excited about
spring and summer movies which for me
can sometimes be scary movies and I
can't wait to talk about psycho with you
it's a classic and I've seen it many
times but I have a lot to say guys thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get steppen eyes
[Music]